- Yeah, I mean, no doubt Trump
wants to run for president
in '24, he's raising
money to do so.
He hasn't announced because
if he announces now in '22,
campaign finance laws
immediately kick in.
That will constrict
his fundraising
for his political
action committees.
So he's not gonna formally
announce till next year.
Donald Trump has problems,
no doubt about it.
He didn't handle the
January 6th thing well.
He continues to harp
on the election,
which is not a good
political way to be,
because he does have
a strong record.
If you look, if you detach--
- Have you said that to him,
about January 6th?
- Oh of course.
- Yeah.
- He doesn't listen to anybody.
Donald Trump never
listens to anybody.
It's part of his charm, he
never has listened to anybody.
(relaxed news theme music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the host of "No Spin News",
and the author of the new book,
"Killing the Killers: The
Secret War Against Terrorists",
Bill O'Reilly, welcome
to "The Rubin Report".
- Thanks for having me
back, Dave, appreciate it.
How you doing?
- Bill, I'm doing well.
I have to tell you,
as someone that just got my
second book out, I am told,
'cause I'm looking at the
cover of your book right now,
this is your 17th
number one best seller.
How many books have you
written in the first place?
- 25, a lot of them
children's books
off "The O'Reilly Factor",
but all of the "Killing"
books have hit number one.
And the "Killing" series,
the "Killing the Killers" is
the 11th book in this series.
The most successful nonfiction
book series of all time,
and that's pretty stunning
when you think about it,
and humbling for me.
- For sure, what do you
consider yourself first?
I mean, do you consider
yourself a pundit first,
or a journalist?
Do you consider
yourself a journalist
in a traditional sense,
or is it an author first?
Does it matter what's first.
- I'm a journalist
slash historian.
Master's degree in broadcast
journalism from Boston U,
network experience
at CBS and ABC.
Seen it all, 84 countries.
So I'm a journalist first, but
I bring a history perspective
because I used to teach
high school history.
So it's an interesting
combination, it's
served me well.
- So let's, I wanna talk
about the book obviously,
but let's dive into just
some of the stuff going on
right now, obviously,
as we're sitting here.
- Sure.
- Abortion and the reversal
of Roe V. Wade is the big one.
First off, are you shocked that,
putting aside the decision,
that we are not talking
about the leak anymore?
that that seems to
have come and gone,
and is sort of
irrelevant at this point,
or at least in terms
of what the mainstream media
will discuss relative to it?
- I'm not shocked because
you got Merrick Garland,
the attorney general, he has
no interest in finding out
who leaked that out
from Alito's office.
Garland didn't have any
interest in finding that out
because it would hurt Biden.
And you have the head
of the US Marshall
Service supervising it,
no updates, no press
conferences, nothing,
and they're just
hoping it goes away.
I mean, look, we
live in a country now
where there really isn't
a criminal justice system,
or a civil justice system
for that matter, anymore.
It's evaporated, now
you have little fiefdoms
all over the place,
and the prosecutor in New
York city doesn't want
to prosecute somebody
who stabs another person,
and he is not gonna prosecute.
And the governors,
and the president,
and everybody else
allows it to happen,
so that's where we are.
- You've been warning about
this stuff for a long time.
- Yeah.
- Do you ever feel,
"Boy, I guess I was right.
"They said a lot of
bad things about me,
"but I guess I was right
about some of this stuff"?
- Well, when you're right,
they're gonna say bad
things about you, Dave.
That's just the
way America works.
If you are right you're
gonna get hammered.
I wrote a book called
"Culture Warrior" way back.
If you read that book,
everything I said in that book,
and that was a mid 2000, about
2004, I think, came true.
I could see the trend
way before it happened,
because what we have is
cowardly politicians.
I mean, that's what
it comes down to.
80%, maybe 70% of
the elected people
in this country are cowards.
They're not interested
in helping the folks,
they're interested in
maintaining their power.
So when you have that,
and you have an electorate
that's largely uneducated,
people dunno what
the constitution is,
they don't what it
says, they don't care.
They want to know what
the latest tweet is,
or what's on Instagram,
and they wanna spend
their lives here.
This is where most
people live now,
right here in this
little machine.
They don't wanna take the time
to understand what's happening
and why it's happening.
And when you get a
voting public like that,
you get California,
you get New York state,
you get Illinois, and
that's what we have.
- So does that, what you're
explaining right there,
really is the perfect
example of what's going on
with the reaction
to Roe V. Wade?
That nobody really understands
this is about state's rights,
and what is and in isn't
in the constitution.
And I guess to some extent,
a certain set of the
society just doesn't care
what's in the constitution,
they just want it
done their way.
- Well, not just a certain
portion of society.
The speaker of the house
representative doesn't care
what's in the constitution,
nor does the president
of the United States,
or the Senate majority
leader, Schumer.
You think any
three of those care
what's in the constitution?
Everybody knew, Ruth
Bader Ginsburg knew,
that the 1973 ruling,
whereby abortion was legal
all over the United States,
wasn't based on
the constitution,
because the right of
privacy is never mentioned.
Now, in the criminal
justice system,
you have a right of
sanctuary in your home.
The authorities cannot
come into your home
without a warrant,
without probable cause.
And that happened because
the British, the king,
they were kicking doors
all over the place.
So the colonists had
no privacy at all,
there come the troops, boom,
they'll take your house.
But as far as abortion was
concerned, was never mentioned.
And because it was
never mentioned,
it then falls under the 10th
amendment, as you know, Dave.
And the 10th amendment
of the constitution says,
"If an issue is not clearly
mentioned in the writings here,
"the amendments of
the constitution,
"the states then decide it."
And that's what happened
with Roe V. Wade.
- So what do we do, what
do we do right now if,
obviously everyone in my
audience watching this,
and hearing you
knows that's true,
but what do we do if
basically half the country,
and as you just said,
a huge portion of the
political leadership,
simply don't care about
the documents anymore?
To me, this seems like a
completely intractable impasse.
You can't negotiate with
people that don't think
that the basic founding,
the basic documents
are good or are worthy of
paying any attention to,
or abiding by.
- I agree that you
can't negotiate
with someone like Nancy Pelosi.
I mean, her own church
can't negotiate with her.
She wouldn't show
up to a meeting
with the Archbishop
of San Francisco,
who wanted to discuss her
advocacy for abortion.
It's more than,
"I don't want to impose my
view of abortion on others",
it's way more than that.
Nancy Pelosi wants
as many abortions
in this country as possible.
Now, how you can be a Roman
Catholic and hold that view?
It's impossible, you can't,
but she doesn't care
what the church says.
Doesn't care what the
constitution says.
She is in it for power.
She understands her
base is left, far left.
She's gonna pander to that base
no matter what the issue is.
She's like Biden, she has no
core belief system at all,
other than, "I believe
in power, and I want it."
- So what do you do with these?
What do you do in
this situation?
I mean, what are
we supposed to do?
Guys like us, what do we--
- There's nothing you can do,
80 million people
voted for Biden.
- You just live, you just live.
- Yeah, I mean,
look, you could move,
or where you gonna move?
- Florida.
- Where you going?
- Florida, my friend.
Come on down, you're
still in New York.
- Okay, all right, but you're
still in the United States.
- Yes, this is true.
- So if 80 million
people are gonna vote
for a guy like Joe Biden,
and believe me, if you
go back and you look
at what O'Reilly said in October
before the November
vote of 2020,
I predicted everything
that was gonna happen
because I knew this man was
not capable of doing the job.
He cannot do it, all right.
And everybody has to understand
that, he cannot do it.
And so you're putting
in an incompetent.
Now, you can say it
is mental decline.
I don't even get into
that, I'm not a doctor,
but I saw he couldn't campaign.
He couldn't utter a cogent
sentence in the debates.
And I went, "This is trouble."
But the populous hated
Donald Trump so much
that they put Biden in office,
and so now we're
all paying a price
for that terrible decision.
- Who do you think is
really running the show?
I mean, it doesn't seem like
you think it's Biden himself.
- Klain is running the show.
Ron Klain is the chief of staff,
and Susan Rice is the
minister of propaganda,
in the sense that
Rice is the ideolog,
the progressive ideolog, and
Klain is the administrator.
But the most powerful person
in the White House
is Jill Biden.
So you don't get to
talk to Joe Biden
unless you go
through Jill Biden.
Very close to Nancy Reagan.
And I wrote the book
"Killing Reagan",
and Nancy after Mr.
Reagan was shot,
she controlled access to
the president, so does Jill.
Now, Jill looks to me like
to be a far left zealot,
she looks like she's right on
board with Rice, and Klain,
and all these others.
Because I don't
see any moderation
in that White House at all.
- So I wanna talk to you
a little bit about media.
Obviously you have an extensive
sort of remarkable pedigree
in mainstream media, and in
what was once mainstream,
I don't know that it's
mainstream anymore,
let's say corporate press.
And you're doing the
online thing now,
which obviously is the
future of all this.
Is there anything you miss
from the daily cable news grind
that you feel like you got there
that you can't get doing
what we're doing now?
- Well, I was at Fox News
for more than 20 years,
16 as the highest rated cable
show in the country by far,
by the way, it
wasn't even close.
And I had pretty much
done all I could do
for the corporation.
And then before that,
I worked with ABC news
as a correspondent.
CBS as a correspondent,
syndicated program
called "Inside Edition".
So I have basically seen it
and done it all in my career.
And when I left the daily
grind, believe me, it was.
Because I write everything
I say, I have no writers,
I never have had any writers.
And I design the programs,
I don't have producers
design 'em for me.
- Wow.
- I'm like Jerry Lewis.
I sweep up after everybody
leaves, I get everybody Cokes.
- Do you have someone that's
doing some fact checking
when you're writing
your monologue?
- Yeah, we have fact
checkers and bookers.
- Yeah.
- I can't do that.
- Right.
- But all this stuff that you
see on screen comes for me,
and I was tired, and it was
a bit change in management,
as everybody knows at Fox,
and it was a different crew.
And I said, they
were gunning for me.
The far left cadres,
and I didn't think I was
gonna get protection,
and it wasn't worth it
anymore, didn't need the money.
And then when I got
out of there, I said,
"Look, the future of media
isn't in the corporations,
"they're all gonna go down."
And they are, every one of
'em is declining dramatically.
But the future is to
develop a news agency
that's independent
from all of that,
and present it to the folks,
and see if they'll pay for it.
And they are, I mean, I
am making a lot of money
on billoreilly.com.
I'm not in it for the money,
I don't do it for that,
but there are hundreds of
thousands of people willing
to pay for honesty, and
that's what I provide.
You may not agree with me,
but I'm gonna back
up what I say.
So I thought it would
work, it is working.
We are the most successful
news agency in the world now.
We're a worldwide operation,
and we combined
television with radio,
and we got more than 300 radio
stations across the country.
So it's all going my way, it's
an enormous amount of work,
that's for sure, but I'm glad
I don't answer to anybody.
there's no dopey meetings,
I don't have to play...
I never played office politics.
I don't have to even be
subjected to that anymore,
so it's a relief.
- Are there any lefty
counterparts doing
something similar
to what you've done,
what I'm doing?
There is this sort of broad,
new sort of right leaning,
conservative thing
happening online
that seems really robust.
All sorts of different people
who are more traditional
conservatives,
libertarians, ex libs.
There's a whole
group of people doing
this really successfully.
Is there anyone that you see
kind of from the other side
that's doing it successfully
that you respect,
that you try to engage with.
I'm having a hard time finding
any of these people
willing to talk.
- Yeah, I don't
live in that world.
I get clip service, and I
know what people are saying,
but I don't live in that world.
But there isn't anyone
on a regular platform
on the net that is looking
at it from a moderate,
liberal point of view, no one.
You wanna take the guy--
- Is that sad for you, I mean,
as you're a Long islander.
- I don't care.
- I know where you
grew up in Long Island.
I'm a Long Islander,
I grew up around a lot of people
who were sort of
moderate liberals,
and they seemingly just
don't exist anymore.
- Sure, they don't
exist anymore,
and it's too bad they
don't exist anymore.
I'm a registered independent.
A lot of the moderate
liberals have gone
into the independent
precincts now.
But if you are not a
doctrinaire progressive leftist,
you get smeared by
your own people.
I mean, they'll attack
you, they'll turn on you.
It's gotta be doctrinaire
down the line.
Look, what's happening
to Bill Maher.
Now, Bill Maher is a very
liberal person, extremely so,
but he then is fed up with woke,
and he knows what's absurd,
'cause he's a comedian and
that's how he makes his living.
He knows Biden's absurd.
He knows the whole
administration is a catastrophe.
Well, he says that,
they turn on him fast.
So he's not--
- You think he'll
ever fully turn,
and do the scariest
of all things?
- No, I don't think so
because he lives in Hollywood.
- Yeah.
- You live in Hollywood.
His cocktail party invites
would been down by about 50%,
I understand.
If he goes into
traditional precincts,
he'll never get
invited anywhere.
And that's what these
people live for,
that's what they live for.
The social aspect of
it, that kind of thing.
The accepted in the
bubble, Manhattan, DC, LA.
It's boring to me, I never
wanted to be in the bubble.
That never affected me at all.
I mean, I exec
produced four movies,
and we were nominated for
three Emmys, and I was shocked.
The movies were really good,
based on the killing books,
but I was stunned.
We didn't win because you're
not gonna give O'Reilly
an entertainment Emmy.
I won three news Emmys,
but that's a bubble out
there in entertainment,
and that's part of the
reason we're in such a mess.
Because entertainment industry
and the media, news media,
they're aligned with
the progressive left.
And that makes a progressive
left far more powerful
than they would be
because they don't have that
great a number of people.
- But the silver
lining, of course,
is that people do
seem to be tuning out,
and tuning into some
of the stronger stuff.
- They are tuning out,
no doubt about it.
- So since you are in New York,
and you are a true New Yorker,
I often show clips on
my show of Kathy Hochul,
a woman who nobody voted for,
who seems to be probably
the second most
authoritarian governor
we have in the country,
maybe to Gavin Newsome,
but she might be number one.
You could probably throw
Whitmer in there too.
What is going on in New York?
Where is that spirit of
New York to fight back,
'cause that's disturbing.
- It's the same thing
that we see in California
and Illinois.
One party in New York Democrats
outnumber Republicans two
to one on the voter rolls.
Kathy Hochul is a person
who will never solve
any significant problem.
She's simply not smart enough.
It's not like Biden, Biden's
a whole different thing.
Hochul is just not smart enough,
and doesn't particularly care,
she doesn't live
in New York city.
She doesn't care if the
city is crime ridden,
quality of life is collapsed,
subways are dangerous.
Doesn't care, doesn't
care that six,
700,000 affluent New
Yorkers have left the state.
Doesn't care.
Again, power, that's what she
wants, she's in the machine.
No bail law, she can knock
that out, doesn't care.
She could fire Bragg, the
prosecutor in Manhattan
who won't prosecute any
even violent crimes.
She could fire him, won't do it.
So my message to New York
voters is, this what you want?
Apparently it is,
apparently it is, Dave.
I don't think Long Island, where
I am, is like that anymore.
Long Island has
changed, all right,
but Manhattan certainly
doesn't seem to care
whether these people destroy
their own environment.
- So to that end,
what do you make
of the splitting of
America in that way?
That we're just gonna have
very, very different states.
As I think you know,
I lived in California
for the last eight years,
finally moved to
Florida six months ago.
And as I keep telling everybody,
I genuinely feel like I
live in another country.
You're right, I do still
live in the United States,
I suppose, but I live
in a free state here,
and I did not live in a free
state only 3000 miles away.
- Well, the social civil
war is well underway.
Would take a dramatic
populous leader
to speak frankly to
the nation and say,
"Is this what you want?"
Again, it's just like New York.
Is this what you want?
If not, let's kind of reason
and find solutions
to vexing problems.
That's what it's all
about, problem solving.
Progressives, they wanna
knock you out what America is.
They don't like the country.
They don't care about
the constitution.
They don't want capitalism.
They want equity, they want
favoritism for minority groups.
They want nothing to do
with traditional America.
But again,
there's about 20, 25% of
those hate America people.
And they'll never
admit that, by the way,
they'll always cloak it.
But the rest, 75%, if
they would come together,
they could overwhelm
this destructive
progressive movement.
But again, they're lost
in space, cyberspace.
And that's what we have.
- Do you sense that maybe
some of that's turned around?
Not only because of
the Roe V Wade thing,
which kicked some of
this back to the states.
But some of the other decisions,
the concealed carry decision.
That some of this stuff
is putting the power back
in the hands of the people,
and maybe that gets to
more people to wake up.
- No, what's gonna
get people to wake up
is that they don't have any
money, that'll wake 'em up.
- Well, then we're on our way.
- So yeah, most Americans
live paycheck to paycheck.
They spend frivolously.
They don't think about the
future in saving, and security,
and more money you have
the more power you have.
They don't think about it.
They want what they
want when they want it.
But now they have far less money
than they had 18 months ago,
and that's not gonna
subside anytime soon.
So the gasoline thing, the
food thing, the clothing thing,
everything, that's waking
up some people to go,
"These people hurt me.
"These progressives
hurt me, Biden hurt me."
That's far overwhelms abortion,
gun control, any of that.
It's that, "I'm getting
hurt by these people,
"so I'm gonna vote
for the other people."
And I think that's
what you're gonna see.
- So you think we're in some
kind of red wave situation?
I mean, that's what
everyone's saying,
but I keep telling people, you
gotta give the devil his due.
It's like they can do anything
right before the elections.
I don't even know what
I mean by that exactly.
COVID to mail in ballots, et
cetera, et cetera, who knows?
- But it's coming down
fast, so the summer is here,
and the government doesn't
function in the summer.
And the media doesn't function,
either everybody's
off, they don't care.
So it fires up again
after Labor Day,
and that's just two months
before the midterms.
It's far too little time
for the Biden administration
to really do anything.
You have a collapsing
airline industry,
and I'm the poster boy for that,
I alerted everybody
that it was happening.
I got hammered,
but I don't care.
What I did was right, it
was proper, it was just.
I shouldn't have
cursed at the guy,
but the guy deserved
it, he deserved it.
And I'm a Irish guy
from Long Island,
and you pushed me so far.
But anyway, I do believe that
the Republicans will take
the house and the Senate.
I think a lot of
Democrats will stay home.
And I think the Hispanic
voting bloc will go Republican,
and that'll overwhelm the
progressives in November.
It's about a 20% chance I'm
wrong, but 80% that I'm right.
- Since you brought
it up, I have to ask,
you're going to
Turks and Caicos,
you're ready to get on
vacation, get out of there,
get out of the grind.
Why not just fly private, Bill?
What are you doing, you
got a little cash, come on.
- Look, I get up at
five in the morning
to make a 7:00 a.m flight, okay?
My assistant tracked the
flight, plane was there,
everything was fine,
weather was fine.
So I get to the gate, delay.
Everybody's in the
same boat I'm in.
One hour, two hours, three
hours, four hours, five hours.
Okay Dave, five hours.
People are coming to me
in JFK, at the terminal,
asking me to do
something, right.
To find out if the plane's
gonna take off, right,
so they're asking me.
So all I did was walk over
and ask for a supervisor,
a guy who could barely
speak English came out.
I said, "Can you tell us
what the situation is?"
He gave me attitude, and the
rest, as they say, is history.
- Do you think the
airline situation,
that that situation
where every time
you go to an airport now
there's delays, cancellations?
I mean the last five times
I've been to airports,
it's been absolute disasters.
That that's
indicative of sort of
everything we're
talking about here?
That the system itself is no
longer functioning properly?
We don't hire
functioning people.
We don't hire people
that speak English.
The buck stops with
nobody, et cetera.
- This airline thing could be
solved in a week, all right.
Who is the secretary of
transportation, Dave?
- That's gay Pete.
That's what we call him
on this show, gay Pete.
- Okay, so Buttigieg
is in charge.
If he wanted to, he could
levy draconian fines
on all of the airlines
for being delayed
for five hours for no reason.
Remember, Delta Airlines
flew to Turks and Caicos
at the same time, and got off.
So when JetBlue
said it was weather,
everyone knew they were lying.
- Yeah, yeah, there's
a lot of that, yeah.
- Okay, okay.
So Buttigieg judge can
say to the airlines,
"If you don't have a
legitimate excuse for delay
"or cancellation, your
fine, $250,000 per flight."
You do it, you got the
power to do it, won't do it.
Now, you say, "Well,
that might not be fair.
"The airlines could
appeal a fine."
And you set up a little
apparatus for them to do it,
but I guarantee you
if Pete Buttigieg,
the secretary of transportation
has the power to do it,
did it, you would see remarkably
the whole airline
industry be responsible
because they're
irresponsible now.
So why doesn't Pete
Buttigieg do that?
I knew you were gonna
ask that question, Dave?
- It was coming.
- I could see
right in your head.
Because Pete Buttigieg,
like President Biden,
doesn't know what
the deuce he's doing.
He is a mayor of
South Bend, Indiana,
where his biggest
decision on Thursday was,
"Should we open the park?"
Okay, that's it, he doesn't
know how to run anything.
He's an affirmative action hire.
Everybody knows that.
- Yeah,
that's why we call
him gay Pete here.
- Pete Buttigieg knows it.
The Biden administration came
in, didn't hire on merit.
"Who can we find out to really
understand transportation
"so we don't have
supply line problems,
"and we can get the airlines
regulated so they take off.
"Who can we get
who really knows?"
That wasn't it, it was, "Well,
we need a lifestyle guy.
"Here's Pete, okay."
Kamala Harris, is she qualified
to run the United
States of America, Dave?
Is Kamala Harris qualified
to run this country?
- Well, she does know
that Ukraine is small,
and that Russia is big.
Now, that counts as
something, doesn't it?
- No, she's there because
she's an affirmative
action hire.
So when you have an
incompetent at the top, Biden,
he's comfortable hiring
other incompetents.
That's the way it is,
that's what we have.
- All right, so let's
move from incompetence,
to perhaps some competence
that could maybe get
involved in this.
Obviously you're an admirer
and friend of President Trump,
and you guys did your tour
together for quite some time.
We've got a great situation
going on here in Florida
with Ron DeSantis.
What do you make of
what's gonna happen
with the Republicans,
and do you have any insight
into what Trump's gonna do?
I mean, it all seems
like he's going.
That every day,
it's another hint.
That seems where it's
all headed, right?
- Yeah, I mean, no doubt.
Trump wants to run
for president in '24.
He is raising money to do so.
He hasn't announced because
if he announces now in '22,
campaign finance laws
immediately kick in.
That will constrict
his fundraising
for his political
action committees.
So he's not gonna formally
announce till next year,
Donald Trump has problems,
no doubt about it.
He didn't handle the
January 6th thing well.
He continues to harp
on the election,
which is not a good
political way to be,
because he does have
a strong record.
If you look, and you detach--
- Have you said that to him,
about January 6th?
- Oh, of course.
- Yeah.
- He doesn't listen to anybody.
Donald Trump never
listens to anybody,
it's part of his charm, he
never has listened to anybody.
The only person on
earth that Donald Trump
ever listened to was his
father, Fred Trump, okay?
And that was about
business, not politics.
So anyway, Donald Trump, if you,
and that's what the history tour
that I went out with Trump on.
If you look at the way
he ran the country,
he was very successful
'cause he ran it on a
deal making opposition.
The reason they didn't
have trouble with Putin
is because Trump made
a deal with Putin.
I don't know what that deal
is, but they had a deal.
Now, Putin's hackers, they've
caused a little bit trouble,
but Putin himself didn't.
Soon as Trump was gone,
Taliban and Afghanistan,
Putin and Russia,
and myriad others,
said, "Okay, now
we got a weak guy.
"We don't have Trump, 'cause
Trump, he's gonna hurt us."
And that's why I wrote
"Killing the Killers",
I show you in that book
how Trump handled ISIS,
Al-Qaeda and the Iranians.
And I'll tell you,
it was pretty tough.
I don't think you
could get tougher.
All right, nobody
knows about this.
It's all classified information
we have in "Killing
the Killers".
But anyway, Trump ran the
country, in my opinion,
but I'm not some
guy who comes in
and I just root for
people, I don't do that.
He ran the country
well, Donald Trump did,
but he doesn't even
campaign on that.
It's all about the election.
The election's not
gonna be overturned.
And here's the real kicker
on it if Trump is reelected,
he could then appoint
a special council
to investigate the election,
he'd have the power to do that.
But to just run around, and
keep doing it, and doing,
people are tired of it.
So he's not a lock, you
said, as you mentioned,
ran Florida pretty well, or is
running Florida pretty well.
Conservative doctrinaire,
so DeSantis would be
a formidable opponent.
- So let's shift a
little bit to the book,
because you talk
about some of the way
that Trump ran policy to get
some of these things done.
When we ran foreign policy
somewhat effectively,
unlike what we're doing today.
You've done obviously
many of these books.
I mean, first off, where
did the original idea
for the "Killing"
series come from?
- Me, all the
ideas come from me.
So I wanted to use my
knowledge of history
to inform people about their
country in an entertaining way.
And it's, as I mentioned,
succeeded beyond
anyone's expectations.
So we did with "Killing
the Killers" was,
I know everybody,
Dave, I know everybody.
- You've been around
the block, man.
- So I contacted the
national security advisors,
beginning with David Patreus
in the Bush administration,
all the way up to the end
of the Trump administration.
And I told them,
they're all men.
I said, "Look, I need to know
"what happened in certain areas.
"I'm not gonna quote you,
I'm not gonna use your name,
"it's just background.
"Tell me the truth, but I will
verify it in other places."
And they all did.
So I got amazing stuff, stuff
nobody's ever heard before.
- So how do they go
about doing that?
I'm always amazed by that.
So are they redacting
specific locations?
You're getting
general locations,
and then you slightly
have to change them, or?
- No, no, no, I say,
"Look you waxed Soleimani.
"Solemani got waxed, okay,
how did that happen?"
And they tell a story,
and I write it down,
and I put it in the book.
- But there's gotta be some
stuff there telling you
you can't write down, right?
- I don't leave anything out,
I don't leave anything out.
Soleimani is the most
powerful person in Iran,
more powerful than the
ayatollah, all of that, okay.
And the way that America
tracked and assassinated him,
it's unbelievable.
Remember, Trump spent $1.4
trillion on the military.
Nobody knows where
that money went.
A lot of it went into space,
surveillance and weaponry.
Stuff China and
Russia don't have.
What we have, and all
of that is in a book.
And when people read the book,
and hundreds of thousands bought
it, they're going, "Whoa."
Because a regular reporter
will never get that stuff,
ever in a million years.
And then when somebody
would tell me something
about Soleimani, or we opened
with the Bin Laden raid,
what really happened,
and we ended with the debacle
of Biden in Afghanistan.
So that's how the book is all
throughout that timeframe.
But when I got information,
I verified it through
people who were there, okay?
On the raids themselves.
And that's what
you call reporting,
and "Killing the Killer"
is the best reporting
I've ever done in my career.
- How would you
grade our mission,
if you go from exactly what
you said the book covers?
From the assassination of Bin
Laden, taking out Bin Laden,
to the disastrous way
we left Afghanistan.
I mean, can you put
a grade on that,
or I guess there's
a curve there?
- Well, the thing I say is that
Americans are well protected
by the CIA and NSA,
National Security Agency.
Those agencies work
very effectively.
Unfortunately they don't have
any sway inside
the United States,
and we have an open
border, inexplicably.
Why Biden did
that, nobody knows,
but terrorists have gotten in
through that Southern border.
Now, the FBI takes that over,
and I have no confidence
at this point in history
in the FBI, none, so
there's a time bomb.
But overseas, we put a heard
on those people, Afghanistan,
Al-Qaeda is there
reconstituting,
but we can listen to almost
every one of their
transmissions.
Same thing at ISIS in
Iraq, Boka Haram in Africa,
we have ground troops in Africa
right now as we're speaking,
nobody knows it.
They're fighting the ISIS people
and Boko Haram people there.
So Americans are well protected
from overseas jihadists,
but is a growing threat within.
- What did you learn about
the Afghanistan withdrawal
that perhaps we don't--
- Oh, it's ridiculous.
- We don't know, I mean,
we all saw the images.
- It's totally ridiculous.
- Yeah.
- Right, so every national
security person told Biden,
"You can't do this,
you can't cut and run.
"You've got to keep
Bagram air force base."
And I've been to Bagram,
I've been to Afghanistan.
"You've got to keep that
as a safe zone, right.
"It's got to be armed, you've
got to have air power there.
"You've got to keep the
terrorists incarcerated there.
"Can't give it up."
Biden rejected all of
it, just gave it up.
Along with all of our
military equipment.
He led 1000 hardcore terrorists
out of Bagram prison.
One of those terrorists,
three days later,
killed 13 US service people
at the Kabul airport.
Biden has no clue
about anything.
And people say, "Oh
Riley, you hate him,
"and you're an ideolog."
I'm not, this is a
flat out analysis.
The man cannot understand,
does not have the intellectual
capacity to understand
what is happening in this world.
- Well, that's a
scary thought, huh?
- He's the second worst
president in our history
so far in 18 months.
Only James Buchanan,
who pretty much caused the
civil war before Lincoln,
tops him.
And maybe Biden will
make a stunning comeback,
I guess it's possible,
but I don't think so.
- So when we left, and it
was a disaster on all fronts,
were you able to talk
to any of our generals
who, I mean, they didn't get
what they wanted in terms--
- I would never
talk to a general.
Ever on any project would
I speak with a general.
Generals are not in the business
of telling anyone the truth,
they're in the business
of keeping their power.
So generals are not in.
Look, I know what
happened in Afghanistan
because I know people who
advised Biden against it.
See, and so I know
that Biden rejected
everything that was
presented to him
for a cut and run strategy
that was embarrassing for,
and emboldened Putin
and everybody else
all over the world.
- All right, Bill, I know
you're tight on time here.
So now when you often
have ended your shows
with the final word and
your final thoughts,
I always try to end
my shows giving people
a little positivity through
this political madness
that we are in right now,
because it always feels like
it's just getting worse,
and crazier and all
of those things.
So despite Biden, despite
the craziness of the woke,
despite all the stuff
that's happening right now,
and the economy,
and everything else,
what gets you going
in the morning
to make you wanna
keep doing this
when you don't have to do it,
and to fight for the
things you believe in?
- My motivation is to
bring information to people
they don't know, but just
think back two years ago.
Just two years ago,
the American economy
was vibrant, robust.
Working peoples wages
were going up quickly.
We had no supply problems,
we had plenty of fuel.
Gas prices hovered around $2.30.
We had plenty of food, we
had plenty of baby formula.
We had a border
that was locked down
as best the government
could do it,
with the migrant
intrusion cut 75%.
That was just two
years ago, okay?
So I say to people it's a
disaster now, it is a disaster.
But it goes in cycles,
it goes in cycles.
History goes in cycles.
The one to serving point is
people in places like New York,
California, Illinois,
they don't seem to be
learning their lesson.
So those states, I'm not sure,
but the country in
general will come back.
As Boris Johnson said yesterday.
- [Dave] Yep, yep.
- When CNN tried to bait him
into saying America was a fading
power, Johnson said, "No."
Our resources here, and the
resources are the people,
the hardworking,
honest people of this country
can bring this country back.
But everybody needs
honest information,
and insight in order
to build that base,
and that's why I'm here.
- Well, Bill, you were
the first cable news show
that I was ever a guest
on, probably a decade ago.
So I appreciate you
coming on and joining me.
The book is "Killing
the Killers".
We're gonna link to
it right down below.
And my parents often see you
on the beach in Long Island,
so one of these days I'm
gonna bump into you out there.
- All right, Dave, don't
frighten me though, just don't.
- It'll be a subtle
tap, don't worry.
- Okay.
- Thanks Bill, I appreciate it.
- Don't wanna Rudy Giuliani,
you know what I mean?
Thanks for having me
on the program, Dave.
- All right, bye bye.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.